hey guys it is the 27th of June today my
name is jeff mcdonald and I've got a top
five for you so you can spend less than
five minutes getting all caught up on
the week's events and then pretending
you're in the know the whole time don't
worry I got you back first up this week
Sony said they will be using the beta of
their game streaming service PlayStation
now to test pricing models the company
are currently staying shorter rentals
will be about 3 bucks while longer term
ones will be between three and twenty
bucks if your initial reaction is
thinking that sort of expensive then you
aren't alone pricing will be dependent
on the type of game and how long you
want to grab it for take for example
final fantasy 13 2 which is by goals for
four hours eight dollars for seven days
15 for thirty and thirty dollars for 90
days and all gets put into perspective
when you consider that you can get the
whole game from amazon for 18 bucks it's
expected that the service will end up
being subscription-based which should
make the prices a bit more reasonable
but right now you guys aren't so tough
next up the xbox one may be losing the
sale battle to the ps4 by a couple of
million units but apparently it's
winning a Facebook popularity contest
the movoto real estate blog conducted a
Facebook tally and it turned out that
Microsoft's console is liked more in 22
US states while the ps4 one in early
nineteen ninety-eight ended up in a tie
but that may well be because of the way
Facebook browned off audience estimates
to check out which states optics which
console you can check out the handy
dandy map which is actually a pretty
interesting overview we've learned that
microsoft made sony dance this time last
year and it's enjoyable as that image is
with no context here's exactly what
happened PlayStation exact Scott Rudy
said when they found out that the ps4
would be undercutting the xbox one by a
hundred bucks at last year's e3 they
were pretty freakin excited Rudy said we
had a feeling they were going to come in
at four hundred and ninety nine dollars
but we weren't sure so yeah we were
dancing in the aisles and high-fiving it
was great even though the Xbox one has
evened out the playing field now with
the Kinect lyst 399 tula bundle this was
a pretty big deal for Sony since the ps3
suffered a whole lot from being the much
pricier system in the previous
generation
minecraft is done pretty well for itself
lately since it's about to have sold 54
million copies and the console sales
have exceeded those on PC and Mac
Developer mojang says the 54 million
units sold is representative of all
platforms but they didn't give us a more
specific breakdown currently the more
successful console versions are only on
ps3 and 360 but they're coming to ps4
and Xbox one this year in addition to
the Vita there are even whispers that
minecraft may make its way to 3ds and
Wii U but we've not had any confirmation
of that as yet do you guys be an end in
sight for minecraft success or not lots
of today Microsoft have a new
catchphrase and may well be on their way
to catching up to the competition the
company revealed their new tagline which
says with the best exclusive spectacular
new franchises and the best multiplayer
community it's more fun on xbox one they
also released a video complete with a
whole lot of xbox one games that you can
expect to land on the system in the very
near future as well as complete lists of
every exclusive and non-exclusive title
coming to Xbox one in addition retailer
gamestop weighed in on the xbox one's
progress by saying that interest in the
console has bucked up significantly
since the introduction of 399 dollar box
earlier at e3 this year they also said
that the new connect less units were
flying off shelves a day after they were
introduced let me know which xbox one
games you're interested in this year in
that comment box down below or if you
prefer you can chat to me on my Twitter
where I'm at turf McDonald this week on
site be sure to check out cam talking
about getting animals to do your killing
for you I cover off on my favorite
creepy villains on the chest and skyrim
mods makes our gate happen
tamriel that is it for me and all the
good gamey stories from this week be
sure to have yourself a lovely weekend
and I will see you Monday